are you guys worried on tour that you
two might start fighting that you two
might go out on tour together
and maybe i've had a great fight with
his tour manager yeah real serious
wrestle match we just choked me out he
was begging me to tap out
it's a legendary story story at
lollapalooza his man
choked my ass out because i told him i
was a a champion wrestler which i was
telling
doug
goodman and he goes oh really so we
started wrestling
and i did i i [ __ ] took him down
she's a good 20 pounds 40 pounds bigger
but he couldn't take it so when i went
to get up he choked me and he knows it
your point is doug goodman wrestled you
you beat him fair and square and then as
you were done
and he gets up behind you
so so he really blindsided you it really
wasn't a fair thing you know why howard
because when i came up there was no um
octagon
we didn't tap out
like your trollers hit you're the winner
so i won but i knew what i was doing
this is a dispute by the way this is
just letting you know i'm not trying to
be contrarian but there's this isn't
dispute where is there you go now you're
starting to fight now we're going to
stay there
let me hear you guys
where are you please come in come over
here doug come on dog
what do you say doug tell you you're
[Laughter]
you say perry did not beat you
no not even close but i maintained that
i beat him he's always maintained that
he beats me how long did the fight go on
doug i mean in your estimation
30 seconds
i pinned you in 30 seconds
then the next 30 seconds was me being
choked going
and he goes he's going tap out tap out
i'm like tap out
i grew up in in the era of you know
athletic wrestling this is you're
talking octagon [ __ ] i'm thinking like
tap out fellas uh how about a rematch
right now let's clear out the equipment
and get down to it